[Música]
en directo américa es hora de hablar de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido en esta edición iniciamos
hablando de la inflación que afecta a la
región américa latina y cómo están
respondiendo los bancos centrales
valentina luego de la reactivación o el
intento de reactivación económica que se
vio tras la pandemia de coronavirus la
inflación se ha convertido en el
principal problema de todos los países
del mundo y bueno aquí no es la
excepción en américa latina según datos
del banco mundial la inflación en la
región ronda el 7% mientras que el fondo
monetario internacional es más pesimista
en sus previsiones y estima que la
inflación en la región podría cerrar en
2022 en torno al 10 por ciento estos son
los países con mayor inflación en
términos interanuales- de la región y
excluyendo casos como el de venezuela o
argentina que tienen una inflación
elevada incluso antes de la pandemia a
la cabeza está brasil paraguay chile
uruguay colombia nicaragua y méxico
este aumento de precio ha hecho que los
bancos centrales del continente
incrementen la tasa de interés algo que
influye en los bolsillos de los
ciudadanos pero que tiene como fin
intentar poner freno al alza de los
precios para entender cómo la subida de
las tasas de interés afecta a los
ciudadanos con préstamos antes con
alberto bernal león director de
estrategia global de expiring desmán y
esto no dijo para una familia de
personas retiradas que tienen sus
ahorros invierten digamos en
certificados de depósitos en un banco si
suben las tasas de interés quiere decir
que por el dinero que tienen ahorrado
van a recibir más dividendos o sea que
eso es bueno eso es una una parte
importante para los ahorradores
incrementar las tasas de interés les da
mal retorno en sus ahorros ahora para
las personas que están invirtiendo que
quieren comprar un auto quieren comprar
una casa y tienen deudas en la tarjeta
de crédito etcétera pues subir las tasas
de interés es una mala noticia porque
porque les cuesta más pagar la cuota de
mantenimiento de esas deudas que tienen
entonces lo que hace esto otra vez
insisto subir las tasas de interés es
como disminuir la velocidad la cual va a
galopando el caballo cuando se suben los
tipos de interés se disminuye un poco la
capacidad y el interés de la gente de
comprar un auto nuevo de comprar una
casa nueva de endeudarse más en países
como méxico colombia brasil y argentina
los bancos centrales ya comenzaron a
endurecer la política monetaria la
agencia fitch rating asegura que las
recientes alza en estos países son
apenas del comienzo de una política
monetaria más estricta aquí algunas de
las principales economías que comenzaron
a subir las tasas una tendencia que por
supuesto siguió
eeuu y otros países del mundo hay países
como brasil que procede nótese a nuestro
invitado desde el año pasado comenzaron
a subir las tasas antes que existiera la
guerra o todos estos efectos
inflacionarios
para contrarrestar la inflación
básicamente lo que hacen los bancos
centrales es subir los tipos de interés
poniéndole un costo adicional al dinero
a nuestro invitado le preguntamos cómo
están actuando los bancos centrales en
la región y cuál es el impacto en las
empresas del aumento de los tipos de
interés esto dijo
qué es lo que se ha visto en
latinoamérica es que los bancos
centrales en latinoamérica comenzaron a
actuar antes de la reserva federal hay
que saber qué decir que brasil ya lleva
más de un año subiendo los tipos de
interés colombia lleva seis meses en los
tipos de interés chile lleva también
como un año siguiendo los tipos de
interés y eeuu apenas lo subió por
primera vez el mes pasado entonces es
importante decir que si hay algo que uno
pueda decir un juicio de valor que no
puedo hacer latinoamérica se le adelantó
un poco a al mundo desarrollado en
términos de subir las tasas de interés
pues cuesta más ciencia incrementa el
costo del endeudamiento entonces si uno
se endeuda por 100 pesos y la tasa de
interés es 5% pues uno tiene que pagar
cinco pesos por cada 100 dólares que
sean deuda si o si la tasa de interés
pasa de 5% a 8% pues uno por 100 dólares
por 100 pesos que estén de donde tienen
que pagar 8 entonces si la tasa de
interés sube las empresas tienen que
pagar más por el capital de trabajo que
usan por las deudas que tienen entonces
digamos otra vez existe lo que implica
es que se disminuye un poco la capacidad
y el interés de las industrias por
ejemplo en invertir en nuevos proyectos
jorge pues a usted ya nuestro invitado
muchas gracias por esta ampliación y
esta explicación económica ya lo invito
a que se quede con nosotros porque vamos
con nuestro espacio de corresponsales en
directo américa edición nocturna
[Música]